120 menschen müssen jetzt in quarantäne
weil einer unbedingt zu einer
geburtstagsparty musste einen
urlaubsreisen da ist zurückgekehrt in
den bayrischen landkreis schwandorf und
konnte dort sein testergebnis nicht
abwarten und sorgte damit jetzt für
dieses corona chaos und da kennt mein
kollege adrian mühlbauer die details und
ist mir nun auch zugeschaltet aber was
genau ist da also passiert gibt es
mittlerweile schon ein testergebnis also
hinter mir befindet sich das zelt in dem
diese geburtstagsfeier mit 100 gästen
stattfand ein 26-jähriger die
eigentlichen apulischen geburtstag hatte
hat gewartet bis eben jetzt im august
und dachte ist ja unbedingt ich erkenne
feiern eingeladen zu dieser feier war
auch ein junger mann der erst aus
italien zurückkehrte am donnerstag
ihm sei gesagt worden so sagt dieser
junge mann dass ihr wenn ihr positiv sei
sein ergebnis binnen 24 stunden bekämen
weil sie am freitag ein ergebnis hatte
ist er abends eben zu dieser feier
gegangen wo sich eben hundert andere
junge leute aufhielten hat dann am
sonntagvormittag sein ergebnis bekommen
eben dass er positiv sei konsequenz die
100 partygäste und 20 weitere menschen
mit denen er kontakt hat befinden sich
jetzt in quarantäne